quel temps fait-il à la surface du
soleil est ce qu'on prévoit une éruption
de placement des sursauts magnétique ou
pire encore une tempête solaire parfaite
qui pourraient endommager des satellites
irradié des astronautes et mettre à
terre des réseaux électriques
ces gens de questions auxquelles
répondra la nouvelle sonde scientifiques
de la nasa et l'agencé spatiale
européenne ont mis en orbite dimanche
sur leur orbite heures dans un domaine
de recherche qu'on appelle la météo
spatiale et ça fait un bout de temps
encore une fois que ce que ça existe
mais est ce qu'on réalise finalement
c'est que on doit vraiment s'approcher
du soleil pour être capable de vraiment
prendre des mesures qui nous permettrait
uniquement de prédire les éruptions
avoir qu'il nous arrive
la sonde va parcourir les trois quarts
de la distance qui nous sépare du soleil
puis rejoindre son orbite à 42 millions
de kilomètres au dessus des pôles
magnétiques de l'astre pourquoi les
pôles parce que c'est là qu'on peut le
mieux observé le champ magnétique du
soleil qui littéralement le réservoir
d'énergie des éruptions et des vents
solaires
on est capable de suivre l'évolution du
champ magnétique aux pôles du soleil ça
nous rend assez chaud mais ça nous
permet une timor de prédire les
caractéristiques du prochain cycle
d'activité l'intensité général si vous
voulez le niveau d'activité sur l'air
auxquels on peut s'attendre dans les
prochaines décennies
la sonde qui est protégé par un bouclier
thermique transporte une dizaine
d'instruments scientifiques dont une
caméra capable de filmer directement la
surface du soleil comme l'a fait tout
récemment un télescope terrestre pour
les astros physiques peuvent aussi
compter sur la sonde parker soleure
depuis 18 mois
c'est une période faste maintenant avec
les nouveaux télescopes au sol
on a plusieurs sondes spatiales qui
observent le soleil la quantité de
données qui nous arrive est absolument
faramineuses alors ça va certainement
faire une différence on va apprendre
beaucoup
je doute que ce soit le point final des
missions d'observation solaire
las on n'atteindra pas son orbite avant
deux ans ici tout va bien elle observera
le soleil durant presque une décennie
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal